good evening afternoon morning night
where are you wherever you are everybody
thank you for joining us uh still have
people rolling in but I'm going to get
started uh hello everybody some of you
might have noticed that uh I am not
Jared Lander uh the general host of New
York R uh my name is Noam Ross I'm a
long time New York R Meetup member
sometimes speaker uh and friend of the
Meetup uh I'm a computational biologist
here in New York and I'm pinching for
Jared today uh as he had to uh travel
suddenly for work
uh but thanks everybody for coming uh we
have like I said lots of people from
pretty far away and I'll just uh jump in
with the announcements uh first of all
uh if any of you
uh are not members of our slack uh
Nicole's gonna uh put a link in the chat
and uh we have oh Jared jumped into the
slack himself so it'll tell you why he
won't be here
um
but you can join our slack because
that's where we have our monthly Meetup
chat our jobs our jobs board and that's
the best place for you to ask your
questions for the Q a at the end of The
Talk
one of the things that's uh in that
slack is our jobs Board of course when
we are uh in person we have uh everyone
in the audience give a shout out if they
are hiring since we can't have everybody
give a shout out here we have a jobs
board uh within within the slack group
uh Jared will let you know that Lander
analytics is hiring they're looking for
an account executive data science
engineer and a shining developer uh my
research group Eco Health Alliance is
also hiring at the moment we're looking
for a research software engineer to help
run our high performance Computing uh
set up and as well as the data services
that we use for our field and lab
scientists around the world if you have
any interest in that please give me a
ping on the New York on the New York R
slack I'd love to talk with anyone who's
talking about that and if you have a job
if you're hiring your organization is
hiring or you know something that people
to meet up would be interested in please
go into the slack and give it a post in
the jobs posting channel it's how we all
sort of support each other here at New
York r
next we have some events coming up uh
the nodes 2022 conference is coming uh
November 16th and 17th and that's a
virtual online free conference that is
around the neo4j developer Community uh
we'll post a link here so you can
register for that event that's coming up
and then the government and public
sector our conference uh run by this
group here at Lander analytics will be
December 1st and 2nd and that will be
hybrid so it'll be in person at
Georgetown University in DC or you can
attend virtually online and we have a
lot of great people there David Shore
from Blue Rose research uh David Mesa
from NASA they'll have Alex gold from
our studio I know they'll be calling
Carlson from the Verena research group
good friend of mine uh who will have a
lot of great things to say and lots of
people from the FDA US Army Department
of Homeland Security and a lot of other
government and public sector groups
uh on the 30th there's a workshop
associated with that conference on
natural language processing for Public
Policy research that William Doan is
going to teach so you can sign up for
that and for the workshop and the
tickets you can use the promo code NY
hack R to get 20 off uh in addition to
uh that the link is in the uh the the
chat and the slack uh
uh there are there are scholarships for
people of color in order to represent
minorities which you can apply for I
will post a link for that as well and
you can apply for that through November
11th and two people attending tonight uh
will get uh free tickets for the
conference and so if you stay on to uh
the end of the talk uh we're gonna pick
people randomly from people who have
signed in and registered uh and then uh
they'll get uh free registration codes
so stick around for the for the whole
talk not just because of what Bob has to
say
um next month we are back in person and
hybrid uh uh for our Meetup we will be
at brain station uh which is a neat
space in SoHo and we'll be joined by tof
Allen who's the developer from rstudio's
uh product products group
um and he'll be talking about uh some of
the work he's doing there uh there'll be
an invite sent out uh either the end of
this week or early next week and you can
join us in person where once again we'll
have pizza for everybody maintain the
decade-long New York city-wide Pizza
ratings uh data set that we've had at
the New York Army up fall all that time
speaking of which I have a mushroom and
meatball slice tonight uh Jared would
tell you something about the like cheese
stickiness or the the the crust
spottiness but mine is just from the
slicery around the corner and then stop
mushrooms and sausage on it
um if you're having pizza for the Meetup
if you're having dinner Post in the
Meetup chat what you are making or
cooking while we're all talking tonight
um and you can uh you know and then next
month we'll actually do it together for
those who are in New York
um I'm about to introduce Bob uh just so
you will have questions at the end
please post all the questions in the
slack Meetup uh chat if you can't get
into the slack you can use the chat but
uh it's always great to have it in the
Meetup Channel because then lots of
people can answer your questions in
addition to us here
so I am very pleased to introduce uh my
good friend Bob rudis uh Bob rudis has
you know 30 years of experience using
data to uh help protect people and their
computers uh a specialty big Fortune 100
companies uh he's currently the VP of
data science at gray noise intelligence
and what he does is uh do uh spectacular
data science and research on
understanding malicious activity on the
internet and helping organizations that
defend themselves through the power of
data he's the author of data driven
security he's the author of more our
packages than I can remember and a huge
contributor to the our ecosystem and the
r Community uh I'll also say he has an
absolutely excellent blog and a
newsletter that's up almost every day uh
the blog is about more data science and
data stuff the the newsletter seems to
be about everything that's kind of neat
with computers besides are and data
stuff then it distracts me daily from
doing my job because there's always a
new new toy to play with in it so
um I'd say go over and read and
subscribe uh to that because it's uh
absolutely spectacular uh tonight he's
going to be talking about democratizing
data science and team comms with quarto
so uh if you're interested uh in quarto
and uh
you know uh the you know how uh well
I'll let I'll let him explain it to you
uh how quarto can be used especially
with multilingual teams we're in for a
treat tonight so Bob over to you thank
you gnome for for that great
introduction
um and it's really great to be here it's
I'm I'm actually really nervous because
I haven't had this R and this isn't
really even our speaking thing I do but
I have been a data science speaking
thing in a while we're going to go
through
a presentation here and
um the the idea of democratizing
everything associated with data has I
think been really important to me even
before this thing called data science
was actually a thing um and it's it's
it's kind of great that I married do I
marry because it's like also like one of
my wife's passions as well too like
trying to help enable everyone to have
the tools and the skills and the
knowledge necessary to do really great
work with data
um and I will get to this a little bit
later
um yeah and as no mentioned like my blog
which I would tell it to be I'll drop a
couple links to it throughout the slides
here um
I have focused mainly on r with that one
on there and I'm going to talk about
like the focus on R and some other
things in a minute too but this idea of
democratizing data science
that doesn't work if you just say are
only right
um there are so many languages actually
that's one of the reasons why I started
the newsletter that no one was talking
about there's just so many languages
so many ecosystems and so many ways that
folks just come into technology come
into programming uh can then hopefully
eventually come into doing work with
data if you want to call it data science
or not that that that's a it's a nice
catch word but data science
and coming up with ways to ensure that
they can communicate with the other
members of the team with other members
of the organization with the community
with with the internet as as a whole
since like we all have you know we can
all do that
um really became even that much more
important to me once I started get
stalking all the folks involved in
creating this wonderful quarter
ecosystem ecosystem that we have here uh
so I'm gonna I'm gonna just really quick
get through some boilerplate stuff on
here um so this these slides are
available I've already dropped the links
to all the amazing uh caretakers of of
your group
um the the one thing I just want to
point out on here is like you're not
like you might not know what this symbol
is on here we're going to get to what
that symbol is in a minute um but these
are the places that you can find me uh
and to kind of do some things and I'm
going to talk about my company not from
like a selling standpoint but I'm going
to talk about data science at my company
uh how I view data science edit how we
are working to democratize data science
internally at the organization and how
we view quarter as an enabler um for for
for doing that that kind of work so you
can find all of my my noisy stuff out
there pretty much everywhere there's
that Blue Shield sometimes there's a
little bit of gold on there for support
for Ukraine uh everywhere that is it's
me if it's not there it's probably not
me
um
I so to to to tease you into staying for
the whole thing um and I mean I could go
really quick if someone wants to give me
like half their ticket or something for
this but like I I I'll take the whole
time it's cool
um I do have some goals uh that I'm
trying to achieve with I'm hoping to
achieve with the presentation
um so I want to like help you folks
understand what those are uh so one of
the main goals if not the main goal of
of this is to help enable your team
members and so you and your team members
um to research to experiment to work you
know basically just to produce the way
and communicate the way that they're
most comfortable and productive doing so
um and that doesn't mean creating a
funnel right like I said earlier into
one language into one tool into one part
of the ecosystem or one tiny ecosystem
um there's not much democratization
about that that's kind of like kind of
exclusivity and that's really not where
we're gonna need to be and where we want
to be
um so Cordo is an environment and I'll
talk about Michael talk way more about
program a little bit but it's an
environment that I guess you could do
like
Automation and programmatic work with it
like and you can generate reports and
stuff with it of course I guess that
sort of went up but like you're not
going to stand up quarter as a like an
ml Ops environment where you're going to
have apis I didn't get any stuff come
out there I'm sure someone's going to do
an amazing hack to do that if they
haven't already because we have such a
great creative ecosystem
um but honestly core I view quarto as a
tool and an ecosystem designed to help
us unify and level up the artifacts we
generate for each other I view the
outputs the targets
um the the really end goal of anything
we do with Cordo as something that
humans are going to read hopefully enjoy
and hopefully get a lot of information
out of and also contribute that back
into
um I also think well it's not gonna be
the blend all of reproducibility like on
that kind of ml Ops API rest that rest
API interface or whatever
um I do think that Cordo goes a much
longer way than even our markdown was
able to get us there and even make files
you know decades before that we're able
to do uh to finally get us to a point
where we can start truly being able to
reproduce each other's experiments
whether that's internal or whether
that's external I'm seeing a lot more uh
noise out on the internet of there being
like less of a reproducibility crisis I
know it's still there for like science
people like I I know it's no problem uh
but it seems to be less of a problem and
growing less of a problem at least in
certain certain portions of the internet
that kind of monitor
um and then like this is kind of mostly
for me but like that's one reason why I
do the newsletter too like I want to I
want to use what the cool kids are doing
like I'm not one of the cool kids but I
want to use what they're doing
um I find Cordo just so cool
um and all the stuff around all the
tooling of all the people all the
contributor years all the creativity
it's spawning it's just super neat and
just being part of that just helps keep
you alive and keep you energized and so
like I hopefully you'll you'll get a
little bit of that bite if you haven't
actually used quarter here
um so I need I need to stop for a minute
um because you're if I've and I I did
drop something on Twitter earlier that
I'm also going to reveal here uh right
after this slide and um
you you hear me talking about
democratizing and letting people use
stuff that they're familiar with and you
know not being maybe an R purist
um and I think I'm fairly certain that I
come off or have tend to come off as
maybe an R purist
um or at least sort of anti and like I
won't mention who the aunties are yet
but like I come off against certain
certain ecosystems out there um I I am
not going to reneg or go back and
apologize for any of that because a good
part of me still actually believes that
certain ecosystems should die a horrible
painful death
um but they're being used by folks
they're being you're they're being used
by folks very productively and what's
even cooler is there's even more things
happening outside of what we're all
familiar with what we all use on a
regular basis that are that are coming
in and they're going to sweep us out
from under the rug if we're not watching
them and if we're not making that part
of what we do and encouraging folks to
contribute from those things so
in the past I I have been quite
opinionated I still am quite opinionated
I don't think that's ever going to
change much to my entire family's
Chagrin and everyone on the internet
um so in this one uh this is not so much
opinionated Bob from male hey our
Hardware from a like you're going to use
R you're gonna use this thing I'm
opinionated that we have to open up what
we do we have to make things more
accessible we we have to bring more
folks on not and this isn't just because
like they work on our company or we like
this is making our ecosystem more
diverse this is getting a whole bunch of
different viewpoints this is getting a
whole bunch of creativity and ideas and
just ways of thinking that we're not
used to and yeah I know I know quote was
a tool and I know this is like you know
we're generating reports we're making
what but this actually changes things
like when people come together and ideas
come together and we build really cool
things together and we share information
together that's where real power have
happened some my opinion here is that we
need to do a better job of bringing in
the entire fold with this so so that's
that's part of what this everyone is
inside of my penny here and again I'm
not apologizing for for previous Bob
um this was going to be a secret that I
just told told everyone on here um but I
thought I would drop it on the internet
just to get a couple more attendees
um so uh big secret there was Zero our
code used in the creation of tonight's
presentation this is a quarter
presentation this is something called
reveal.js I'm fairly certain that like I
recognize a lot of the names on the
attendee list so I think every single
person there probably knows what Cordo
is and knows what reveal.js is
um quarter wasn't just about reports and
it isn't just another version of our
markdown and it isn't you know isn't it
isn't that like quarter was an entire
broadcast
um one of them is the ability to create
presentations and this is a reveal.js
presentation on here
and I actually deliberately set out to
do this presentation I mean first first
of all it is there is no code in the
presentation I'm not showing a look at
code I actually that's not entirely true
I show screenshots of code so I guess
that counts as that
um but it was entirely made with python
yeah python everybody ever wake up I'll
give you a chance a minute to get
smelling salts or whatever so with
python
um and with something called observable
we're going to talk about observable
later
um so I got I'll drop that later
um and I guess I'm fibbing a little bit
a little bit with no R was used in this
thing so if one call to like our vest
read HTML and pop it out some HTML is if
that counts as our code to you okay it's
not in the presentation there's no
arcade like in the in the directory tree
but I did do that so like if there's a
mail call I guess there's three lines of
our code but still like for me like
that's like that's like nothing's like
that's like I I can sleep and dream
through our three pretty quickly
um so one reason why
um I care deeply about this let's bring
all the folks into the fold is that 10
years ago and like it's probably
arguable that this really wasn't as
simplistic as I'm making it but 10 years
ago what we do right now for living
because we're all doing something
related to data science with this uh our
our universe was a lot smaller than it
is right now um this is a 2021 I think
because I don't think Matt has actually
dropped a one for um 2022 yet uh but it
does one almost every year um and this
is the current ecosystem of data and AI
um that was cataloged for 2021.
um I I will uh see if I can remember how
to do my clicks inside here so like it
goes from everything from like
infrastructure and like all of the
things that you can like just pour skads
and scads of money into like AWS which
is terrible
um or databases or everything out there
and it goes to you know to every single
thing like you know ETL and
transformation things
um monitoring observability like these
are all all components of what most
things happen in data science shops now
it isn't just about running some R code
and even in Academia it you I mean I
think there probably is some cases where
you can just sort of isolate yourself
and do some things I kind of saw that
while my my oldest son was going to
school for physics I guess you can't
compartmentalize yourself if you want to
um but the reality is there's just so
many things out there like even down
here for like data sources and apis
there's just some things like you have
to touch all these things to kind of go
to kind of go do that and there's so
many ways that you can access those
things and you've got query languages
like Galore and all sorts of ways that
we can actually do things on here
um so like you can take a look at this
and like and dig into it the URL is down
there but it's also in the presentation
um if we lock ourselves into one way of
thinking if we lock ourselves into one
way of communicating if we lock
ourselves into one one way of doing
documentation or sharing knowledge and
information like with the rest of our
peers with the rest of the company with
the rest of the planet
um we're like I I just don't know how
you can do that and be successful in
2010 22 and Beyond I guess you could try
to be
um but a pure shop is I don't think
you're going to get the the the best
combination of folks together to to
build the best thing that we possibly
could
um so there's a lot out there and this
is a giant reason why I'm hoping to
convince everybody here to get on the
Cordo train uh to adopt a multilingual
data science shop or it shop or however
you want to phrase what all you folks do
um kind of bring all those things
together
um so I'm going to talk a little bit
about data science at Great noise
intelligence where I work mostly because
I want you to see that like the life of
a cyber person is either as cool or as
boring as as how you may feel like your
data stands like to be in your
organization
um so okay one thing you probably don't
have is planetary scale passive sensor
data wherever you look at what
everything's happening on the internet
you probably don't have that if you do
you definitely need to talk to me after
this or you hit me up if I don't know
you already
um except that most of my time I mean
and I wish I could ask for hands on this
at the webinar so I can't I realize that
but if you're in if you want to just
like show your support inside the psych
Channel which I'm also not in
um a lot of my stuff is Group by
summarize
um a lot of my most productive data
science a lot of my larger insights a
lot of the ways that I communicate best
with like the average individual out
there is with the group by summarize and
like knowing how to divide by the right
things and how to group by the right
things and how to exclude the right
things like all of the stuff that's
involved in that you guys all know that
it's kind of a running gag in data
science a lot of my life is like that
um and I really I liked doing that part
of it because I I like to be able to
explain things to folks and this is the
easiest way that I found to explain
those things
um we also do like other fancier things
like you know fundamental time series
analytics on all this event data that
way that we get like flowing through our
system uh I believe it's gonna be in
like mid-ish November I'll blast it on
Twitter so you'll see it but we're
actually going to talk about like the
size and scale and scope of everything
that we have at green eyes and a blog
post I'm not going to bore you here on
that one uh but we have a lot of data we
have a lot of events we have like over
5000 sensors across the planet
um in networks everywhere the like some
of them might can't even tell you where
they are and like we get a lot of data
we get a lot of Eventing in the time
series stuff it's actually pretty
fundamental um to what we've been doing
and especially what we're going to be
doing moving forward
um and then we do fancy I'm going to put
double quotes in that because like every
time I log on and see something with
stable diffusion I kind of just shake my
head and like go like this because like
nothing I do even comes close to how
cool that is
um but we have our own fancy mlna things
that are pretty neat and we also have
some blog posts coming out about out the
details of those things as well too so
again I'll know you on Twitter about
that I don't I don't need to take a
whole lot more time on here for there
um so this hopefully sounds a little bit
at least like some of the shops like
that are out there that you folks are in
uh the scale like I know I know JD's on
and like you know JD's like financial
data scale and crop data scale and
things like that it's close to if not
more sometimes than some of mine so some
of you have that scale thing some of you
are data is like a lot smaller and
that's I would sometimes kill to work
with smaller data more often too
um so we work with that data uh we also
the data science team works with all the
website blog however you want a phrase
like the things that when people touch
your website or touch your application
uh we work with all of that data as well
too um we we we're not just cyber data
scientists we are you know just data
scientists we want to use data to make
our organization function better enable
all the people in our organization to do
better work and do awesome work and and
this is one part of it so we can know
what kind of effect we're having are we
doing the right things
uh business intelligence I mean I
remember when that was the term like
first came out like that's I do have the
gray hair to show that uh but all of the
things that Encompass that The Good the
Bad and the Ugly around business
intelligence like so we we do all that
as well too
um and then you know we try to get sales
just like the rest of you folks um sales
so sales enablement sales sells insights
all over those things um we we kind of
do those things there there's a method
to this madness
um and then any question that my boss my
wonderful awesome boss
um I'm not really sucking up because if
anyone follows me you know that I I
break him regularly on Twitter uh but
everything he asked me everything the
government's out there ask us for uh or
anything that our users or Community
asks uh we we do our best if we can
answer that data as they answer those
questions as well too
um so everything that I put up here is
you know there's some analytics but
there's a lot of communication happening
on on this side of the bullets over here
and if your organization is even
remotely similar to this um You probably
have a lot of that as well too
um so we're trying to work with all
these folks trying to provide insights
to all these things uh we're trying to
communicate across all of those things
across all those people
um so we use a lot of tools for those
things now I came on board uh earlier
this year as kind of the only R person
like I am still like for not everybody
like I am still a giant believer in our
I love our if I want to make anything
pretty I make everything pretty and R if
I want to do any hacking or testing or
experimenting it all starts with r just
because I'm not using it here doesn't
mean that I don't I don't love the Arca
system
um but I came on board to a bunch of a
bunch of folks who don't know are or at
least R isn't even like in their primary
set of languages like they could
probably get around like with bike if
anyone's familiar with the Monty Python
thing like so they can get around like
any like my hovercraft is full of eels
kind of way
um but but but they're not really you
know developed really into r that much
uh we are primarily a golang shop uh so
if anyone like I think everyone knows
what go is but go is language developed
by Google it is actually really good at
creating uh scalable services
I was I was going to say secure but like
I'm a rust person now as well too so I
have to also like so as much as I will
rag on python as an art person that will
rag on go as a rest person I have to
have a nemesis for every everything that
I have
um but go is a great language uh the
services that makes a great we have some
incredible I mean the talent of the
GoPro programs they are they are just
phenomenal
um we have we we live and die by Jupiter
notebooks and a lot of facets of the
organization
um we also I mean not everything that's
in a Jupiter notebook not everything
belongs there even data stuff right so
there's some python random Python
scripts as uh or just random scripts in
general as I'll mention
uh but you know when I came on like I
brought with me all my our markdown
talents even though quarter was an
emerging thing but I have a lot of our
markdown skills and talents out there so
I bring those in and I if everyone knows
me by my blog or the stuff I throw in
into into my GitHub Repose I have a lot
of random R scripts uh so you bring
those in as well too for those things
um and I've been over the past couple
months experimenting with like the rust
data ecosystem and there is a rusted
data ecosystem and I will briefly talk
about that um a little bit later in in
the presentation uh experimenting with
that because I do think rust is one of
those upstarty things that y'all should
be keeping on your radar when it comes
to doing data work
um and that's not just because I like it
I just I I think I have a good handle on
where things go and like this is one of
those things where you might want to
keep your eye on this one
um I am also a purist when it comes to
certain things and we are an AWS shop um
I know some of the other team members
that I have will gladly use Pi spark and
Pi spark scripts inside glue
um if you have if you if you like your
bank accounts at your organization and
you like performance you will try your
best to learn Scala to do your glue
scripping
um I mean if you can afford not to
that's great but I found on my previous
organization uh Scala works way better
than that inside the inside that spark
environment at AWS um and I much prefer
Scala over overwriting anything in that
other language I mentioned uh we write a
lot of SQL I mean uh I'm sure this is
I'm sure everyone else on on this does
too there's a ton of SQL and if if if I
guess if organizations aren't treating
SQL as a first class language and and
citizen inside your organization
um do you really need to rethink that
SQL is still the lingua Franca of
everything we do
um like so that's like some of the
language things that we actually end up
doing uh we have Jupiter Hub Jupiter lab
um we we have a really cool setup that
one of my uh folks uh Batman Layman set
up uh we will be documenting this I'm
not going to bore you with that with
that set up but you can ask me questions
after this and I'll be glad to tell you
anything I'm just signing the detail
here I talked about this thing called
observable
um I love observable and I will I will
speak politically hopefully about it in
a little bit uh but observable and
JavaScript Java JavaScript is eating the
world um so if you haven't plugged into
JavaScript you really should plug into
it at least a little bit and be really
familiar with it at least on that level
um I love raw grass it's actually a
JavaScript thing but it's a great it's a
great way to prototype data
visualizations if you do not uh use raw
graphs and if and also support raw
graphs I hardly encourage you to it is
free but you can also do support for the
folks uh it's a massive it's a massive
great environment for experimenting of
course our studio our studio is never
not running on any one of the systems
that I have it is always running there's
it is I mean unless I'm updating it then
like for like a second it's down and
then it goes back up
um I'm still a big Sublime Text fan
because I've just been using that
forever and it's got a rich ecosystem
and quarter works with it and the court
works with our studio too
um I also use like remote things a lot
so I use everything Vim Vive however you
want to pronounce it in your thing
there's a lot of really cool things with
that right now uh it's way better than
certain things except Visual Studio code
Visual Studio code I have to see
something nice about Microsoft I'm sorry
about that for anyone that's like me who
doesn't like to do that
um it's a great ecosystem I the editor
is one of the best things for using
rusted it's also one of the best things
for using quarter at too so if you're
not used to using that you know
definitely do that and one reason why I
have this slide up is I want you to take
a look at this just one more time right
so there's go and go does a lot of the
crunching part of algorithmic things
like you know API things and stuff like
that but we've got like Jupiter and
Python and R and I'm playing with rust
and like there's a bunch of languages
and SQL it's like that's that's a lot
already right there that you're trying
to accommodate and then like there's
other there's all these other
environments that are out there but
especially like Visual Studio code and
just our studio just limiting it to
those two things like if you're just in
our studio shop you've just like
removed like three quarters of the
planet of people that can do the coding
work data work uh from being able to
work with you sure they can use our
studio it's a great environment but they
could be like Wicked more productive and
the thing that they're actually familiar
with so
um this is one reason why I'm talking
about democratizing because this is a
really diverse ecosystem it's maybe not
as diverse as some some of the folks out
there but I find this to be really
really diverse and if we were locked
into one thing I don't think we could
get nearly as much done without having
the flexibility to do these various
things
um so all that they are equipped to what
I would call chaos
um and so you got pandas and like I'm
not gonna follow all these little lines
out to there but basically if you don't
have a unifying source for all these
things and that could be in a lot of
different ways like if you're really
great with like Targets on R because R
can do lots of things which I'll talk
about in a little bit or make files or
or for me like I'm I'm a big just person
like not like being just injustice like
there's this tool called just it's
better than make it's a lot easier than
make um like if you're used to those
kind of things like I'm sure you could
you know use something like that to
frame and wield and kind of do all
things out there but that's a jury rig
system that you've probably set up on
your own and it's custom and it's just
all yours
um I what I really want and what I saw
with the potential again when I was at
get stalking the early the Early parts
of of Porto I saw quarto as the unifying
force for all of these things that used
all this spaghetti mess that you see on
here
um and it isn't just because it supports
all the languages out there uh my big
thing with this again is not like hey
this is how we're going to create an
algorithmic pipeline to do XYZ you know
this is how we're going to communicate
and document and share and learn and
Build Together within an organization
um this is chaos and Cordo I believe it
gets rid of this chaos if you do it
right and enables you to get a lot of
benefits out of that and Beyond just
like getting rid of chaos
um so like if you're doing stuff in the
slack chat if you just if you have
something similar in your just drop that
in there so like these folks can let me
know if you actually share some of those
things
um one of my bigger things that I really
like I'm bummed about like is this paste
it into Google Docs word Confluence
because I have to tell you like dealing
with Google Docs um actually just as an
aside for here like I remember years ago
uh with one of the our open side
unconference things and people were
really excited and I think none was even
working on one of these things too
trying to get a workflow to go between
like R and R markdown and Google Docs
and like like I would still kill for
that workflow because Google Docs is
just so terrible at reproducibility and
doing it I mean I know there's ways of
exporting because I following all the
gets talking thing and I see people who
come up with ways of maybe getting
marked down out of there but getting it
back in is going to be hard or whatever
so like this is just a nightmare of
being able to organize control like to
deliver develop unified this is just
crazy so hopefully I'm going to give you
a getting around that uh well so we're
going to be up so welcome to Cordo um
this is just their website and so you
can go there it's unsurprisingly
cordo.org there's a link in here too in
the slides I hope I think you're
probably a blinker ready so you can go
to it
um it's so it's it's just amazing right
so like anyone that was familiar with or
is familiar with our markdown it's kind
of the same thing right you can do cool
Dynamic stuff you could do cool static
stuff you could do both and diverge and
go out there
um but like now you're not just limited
to who are and like a little bit of
hecky way that R worked with python for
a while there yes there are ways of
doing more things into there but it was
really like a gen one thing it was a it
was amazing what you could do with our
markdown and all the folks around with
that took all the things that they
learned from there and all of the warts
and all of the great stuff and said hey
how can we do this better and like this
so this isn't just gen 2R markdown this
is like a reimagining of how we're
actually going to do this kind of work
um so you get to author things however
you want to do you want to use them do
you want to use neovim do you want to
use vs code do you want to use rstudio
or Sublime like what do you want to use
go for you want to use Jupiter notebook
directly go for it
um like so you get to choose whatever
you want to use for these things you're
not limited anymore to like one one
format one tool one everything and you
get all the same benefits of it too
right you actually get to be able to
produce those interactive things and I
didn't put it in the presentation
because like I really did want to just
click add something onto here but if you
haven't seen the announcement this week
about like the ability to just throw up
shiny app within like a quarter dock
output
um it's a and like I'm gonna say it's
amazing because right now they only have
the python part working it's basically a
wasm and if you don't know what that is
we can talk offline but it's a was under
python back end for shiny inside the
document creating a this this opens up
so many possibilities and they are our
stuff is coming real George is amazing
um but there's lots of stuff we could
use like this like I'm setting it up
hopefully you'll have a good experience
with this as we keep going
uh so why is it called Cordo and if you
haven't watched uh Tom Ox uh uh uh if
you haven't watched his tutorial or is
our studio conf talks uh there's a link
to things that have linked to that on
there later so I tried to make an
aggregator versus like coach link crazy
you must if that's a must read that is a
must watch and as much as you have to do
that I call them one of the courtyard
deities
um on Twitter because he's just so
knowledgeable about this and he's just a
great person to follow and just ask
questions and if he doesn't know the
answer he finds the answer
um cordo's named after an actual
document format that kind of appeared
back in the 1400s
um it was literally how you would fold
how you would print out something onto
like the typeset press back in the day
so you could fold it into booklets um
and Gutenberg actually created booklets
and like and you know like um
newsletters or however you want to
phrase like stuff that you could just
like hand out uh with the quarter format
before he even did like the Gutenberg
Bible so he was they were democratizing
knowledge with this with you with the
offset press and with this this format
um way way way way back then and this
this caused like an amazing change like
this just changed everything
um I won't say this booklet only changed
everything but this was a huge Catalyst
for it
um I I'm a big believer like I'm a huge
fan of the old connection series if
anyone's ever like seen the James Burke
series
um I believe this was a catalyst for
tons of things he doesn't talk about it
directly in that series but I think this
did if I could trace it it would change
everything like on there
um and I want quarter this quarto I want
you to use this quarter that we're
talking about now to do the exact same
thing so
what are the sweet spots that I'm going
to talk that we're going to fit that
we're going to like breeze through but
like basically give you a taste of this
tonight so corto's organizational Sweet
Spot number one is a documentation
um I hate documentation I I my and my
team will will if you were to ask them
like if we ever had like an ask me
anything whatever they'll let you know I
I actually hate documentation like I I
don't mind writing but writing for the
point of like doing documentation just
sometimes it just gets to me Porto
actually makes documenting things fun
because you can actually make really
cool documentation that isn't just
boring words but interactive stuff and
drop people in and Link people around
and change things up and like this is
really neat
um and it's a way you can unify all the
documentation in your organization so if
someone wants to write docs or something
and they want to use Python code to do
that let them write the python code for
it or if they want to use r or even you
know something else to plug into there
because it's super plug-inable
um you can actually so I think Cordo
could be the way you unify at least the
data science part of documentation that
your organization um if not all the
other ones out there
I think the the secondary Sweet Spot
which is different than just
documentation is communication
um I think a lot of data science teams
and I think research pairs me out on
this one failed because they just they
don't capture the imagination of the
organization they don't communicate in
the language they need to to the
organization
um they don't make their stuff look cool
um just to be honest about it sometimes
um Community able to have that
communication and regularly tell people
what's happening and regularly encourage
folks to interact with you and make
things look compelling and have them
look like everything else in the orgs
brand and everything is great so
communication is a huge part of the
Puerto Rico system to me so hopefully
um as we talk about things and as I'm
doing this like you can see how that
actually goes into there
um I think style is also an un uh
unheralded thing in a lot of places
because I mean honestly like
unless you've seen someone who Masters
like the python data visualization like
at any like basic python data
visualization kind of looks as bad as
anyone's first ggplot2 that back in the
day use like the basic gray background
and didn't have any styling and it's
great and it is great like your first GG
plot 2 is amazing whoever creates one if
you're just new this and you're it's
amazing it just isn't going to look like
the bestest thing in the planet out
there because until you get better at it
um uh Cordo encourages
emphasis on style that's another reason
why I liked it a lot better over like
what where our markdown had ended up
being like The Styling part was sort of
an after effect on there this is the
first thing like this is the first
principle thing for Cordo like actually
designing up front with modern standards
around style is all about this it what
happens there so I again I'm not doing a
technical talk on this but it basically
uses a version of CSS that are sort of a
meta version It's called scss
um and you basically get to Define
Styles and you know what that means you
get to work with all the designers or
branders in your organization who know
this stuff like crazy I I work with some
of like the most amazing designers who
who think things and build things and
can just imagine things that I can't
begin to and their sense of style is
just incredible and I get to just riff
off of that I get to make my stuff look
great because they make stuff look great
just by the way to design things so you
get to tap into that knowledge and then
you actually learn a skill set as a
result of that too that just empowers
you and and gives you significant more
um capability within do it on your own
um and then I think the final one is
reproducibility uh and I think this is a
problem in a lot of shops maybe maybe
you've solved it on yours I I don't
think we've solved that on ours because
um environments are hard to maintain
um actually getting to the point where
you can actually make things work on
someone else's system is better than it
used to be but it's still not great
sometimes uh so one thing that
especially if you focus on the
documentation side and organ organizing
everything together side uh
reproducibility is really Paramount in
this because uh and I'm I will I will
talk a bit more but basically if you
want to be able to uniformly deploy a
bunch of documentation or gather one
around to put all their stuff into one
place and generate stuff on the file so
you can navigate around to it it's got
to be reproducible um and there's baby
steps to get there but the reality is is
if it's not it's not going to work so
this is a great way to force the
environments to actually work together
and to make things work pretty well
all right so one so how does it do all
this like how does quarter like how is
quarter so magical like exactly what
Alchemy you know did all the folks you
know that were formerly in our markdown
and now in this and all the new ones
that have come on what have they done
like to make this actually work
um so it's it's got batteries included
so there's first class citizens R Python
and Julia
um and also observable and JavaScript
and if again like you may not know what
that is which was what the Watts for uh
we'll talk about that in a little bit
more detail in a minute not too much
more detail though because I tried to
keep this like really code light those
are all first class citizens in here and
eventually you could do the same thing
in our markdown like I said before but
these are like first class like 100
first class citizens now
um they there there is nothing between
them that that is not shareable
um but I'm also lying um I try not to
lie too much uh but I'm lying to you
because R and python um I guess Julia
too but our our JavaScript to a lesser
degree but like but but our our python
especially Julia as well they are built
in extensibility so I will focus more on
what I love and care about more which is
our I mean you could use JavaScript via
V8 and like the new version of your of
of the the V8 uh compatibility that your
own's put in there like you can do
amazing things with that in art right
now
um our job of what Simon started and is
still keeping keeping going and pumping
along despite Oracle and Apple's best
efforts the kill Java for whatever
reason
um like that's still powerful and
there's still so much things you can tap
into on there and reticulate you can
basically like not have to touch a key
Python and just use it for Martin it
then doesn't feel so bad
um so I guess I'm still a bit
opinionated like I said before
um but that's all and there's I mean I
just like that's a bare minimum of the
things you can do for more with other
languages and again python does the same
thing too so I'm lying because you get
to tap into all those ecosystems be with
just those primary citizens out there
um and it actually goes way beyond that
so here's where you might want to if
you're not sitting down again you might
want to sit down
um because because you you don't have to
rely just on ours knitter your engine
which is how our markdown documents used
to have to get data and pass data
through and make all the code work and
all the things that put right you get to
use like the Jupiter kernel ecosystem to
be able to do that and like this is I
mean so this is this is a um uh an
observable JavaScript
entity that I created on here and I'll
show you how I will actually show you
not directly but I will give you an
indication of how I brought it into here
um so it's an interactive visualization
inside the actual thing in in the the
real JS presentation from from Porto uh
these aren't just like I just scaled
them because I wanted to have some
bigger than the other um so there's not
there's no reason for the scaling except
I was opinionated uh but like yeah
there's this is like 148 I think it was
the last count Jupiter kernels
um which means that like you have that
entire and like this you can see like
you got PHP you got you gotta go you've
got ocamel which is actually pretty cool
language
um like every there's a whole bunch of
other things that you can tap into so if
you have folks that know these other
languages and can figure out how to work
with data in those languages or have
been working with data I mean you've now
just democratized the access to that
because you can do all that with quarto
just by switching from Knitter to to
doing that in in in in inside anything
you do with Cordo it's kind of
incredible it's kind of amazing
um especially since I got rust working
with it to so like it's like so it's
really great like there's just so many
things you can do with that
um to extend the capabilities and do
that democratization that I was talking
about before so this is one reason why I
did start off with that democratization
there's I don't think and actually it's
not really hard to make a Jupiter kernel
it's not like super straightforward you
have to read a lot and you know trial
and error but once you do that like once
you follow the rules it isn't that
difficult to do
um and that means any language that
comes out you could do that for and Bam
now you can do data work inside that
language because it has access to all
the objects that you can put into there
um this is phenomenal like this is
unheard of like the ability to do this
before like I don't think I know of any
other thing before Cordo that would give
you the ability to do all this with a
focus on communication unifying
documents putting all things together
communication I just don't think it's
existed before this is this is kind of
amazing
um so observable um so like so yes now
that I've said some nice things about
python I have to actually let's let's
pallet cleanse and move on uh so
observable is one of the things I also
love right now
um this is an ex it's like the
commercial I I will call it the
commercial extension to D3 even though
it's really not because you can just use
observable stuff without actually paying
for anything
um so it's sort of commercial like
they're actually trying to make some
money off of it I think they should
because I think they've developed a
really good thing so if you go to
observablehq.com because they couldn't
get observable because the main
squatters
um it basically lets you experiment with
cool JavaScript but actually not even
just JavaScript because thanks to this
thing called webassembly or wasm you can
experiment with almost anything inside
here too so it's almost as rich as the
quarter worker system but it's kind of
locked into the browser and we won't go
into the details here
um but if you ever wanted to play with
D3 if you ever wanted to play with
JavaScript and you wanted like a like a
a worry-free crash free destruction free
environment go to observable sign up get
an account it's free play with stuff on
there because like you get to learn and
play with a lot of things that are
actually out there and work with all of
the all the observable notebooks that
everyone's already made before
and I when I saw like and like I saw
this I saw this emerge into the repo as
I've been again I I get stopped like 300
or 400 people
um when I saw they had this like on my
like my eyes like literally lit up when
I actually saw it because oh my gosh
like did they make it easy to embed
observable things somewhere and work
with JavaScript code inside other places
and like the answer is yes
um so like I and as an example on here
and I'm not going to go into details on
here but like uh what's on the left is
one of the quintessential D3 interactive
Sankey diagram examples
um
and if you were to go to that URL you
can barely see on there but there's I
got links to this later so don't worry
about it
um you could go in there and play with
all that stuff on there and and deal
with all that on there but it's still
like in there and you could embed it
with a really like kind of I hate to say
this because it's a really good
ecosystem but it's really it's like a
jury rigged way of embedding this stuff
into your website before just using that
code before
um what observable gave us sorry what
what Cordo has given us is the ability
to just write code as you would write
your R code in a markdown document or
python code in a notebook or marked on
document or whatever
um and when I saw that like I I spent
like I maybe two months copying and
pasting stuff out of my private
observable notebooks and two stuff to
play with I just got sick of doing it uh
to be honest with everybody like I'm
like I don't want to do this anymore I
want to be able to play with observable
things inside this environment which is
a lot more friendly to me I do that so
um this is just a plug for a free Chrome
extension which means any any observable
notebook that you see out there and this
is basically two screenshots this is the
only code I think in here
um you basically get a zip file that
works immediately with Cordo so you you
what that what you see on that right
side is the version of it's a visual
studio code uh that is just running and
compiled that and now it's it's
completely interactive thing you could
do the exact same thing works completely
local on your system and now you can
extend that locally and do some cool
stuff and I've got some links later as
well too so what's what makes this super
powerful and what makes me continue this
hey let's democratize things let's build
multi-language things is into here I am
way better at our code than I am a
JavaScript code
um maybe from like a data crunching
perspective anyway like I am scared like
I am leagues better
um at doing that and so one of my fave
things to do now is to do a lot of data
work in our grab whatever data I'm
working with on our take get into a form
that works really really well with
observable and then do all of that work
inside Cordo and tweak and experiment
and play and then publish and I get
everything published on here and and
just to go back like that's what this is
like I basically made this an observable
notebook I clicked that button that I
just showed you I brought the code down
and I literally copy pasted the code
into the into the reveal.js thing and
basically gave me an interactive
um word cloud on here like that's how
simple this is to actually kind of go do
and that's how it just works that's how
well they thought of everything together
uh this actually is the most friendly
way that you can take observable and
bring it to your website or bring it to
your brand site or bring it into however
you want to actually show those things
and if you go through observable and
like click around like the amount of
like hey just here's some really cool
code that does this amazing thing
um you go click it clone it put it into
here and now you just get to shove data
into it and it just works
um so it's even a little bit nicer than
the HTML widget echo system which it
works great enough I have zero against
HTML which is I still use them but this
actually gives you the power beyond that
because you don't have to have
everything conforming to it and you're
not logged into r or even python because
Python's got the same kind of widgets
out there too
um so I've I'm gonna we're four slides
till the end uh so reproducibility
um I'm not gonna talk a lot about this
but basically I my suggestion to here
and I'm going to give you like a plan
for how you should attack quarter and
how you should bring it into your
organization because because it's how
I've been doing it
um the quarto is this great thing
because while you've got all these GUI
environments and Ides and everything
fundamentally you just can go to the
command line you do Corridor render and
you can do quarter render of a single
document you could do quarter render of
entire website an entire book or a
presentation because I just did it or
all of the above if you've got the
project set up correctly
um quarter render will render everything
so if there's python notebooks in there
it will do that if there's code in
python or whatever inside like a
particular qmd document it will do it
into there so by actually making it so
that you have to code or render thing to
have the documentation look right or be
right or stand up write it or whatever
this is like this is the ultimate test
for reproducibility like just the are
you brave enough to put all your code
into one repo like one documentation
repo do code or render without doing
something which club freezing which I'll
mention in a minute are you brave enough
is that going to work in your
environment this this encourages you to
actually go do this so This encourages
you to have reproducibility and the
setups for all of the folks in your
organization to all the servers in your
organization uh bring all that tooling
that people are using and from that
diversity that I talked about into one
particular space
um Corridor renders the ultimate
reproducibility test for me for
something is like let's say a large
large multi-language multi-tool
documentation project
um and I this is the quarter render
challenge for all of you that have like
multi-tool environments if you can do
that you're well on your way to having
reproducibility
all right so I gave you a bunch of like
goals at the beginning we walked through
a bunch of things now on here I've
talked a lot about the things about
showing a lot of code sorry you can look
at the presentation but that's a good
presentation
um what's the value proposition again so
I'm not just going to take the four
things to the beginning and put it up
but I'm going to give you a couple
different ones um Porto is access to
language agnostic kind of completely
language agnostic especially with arrow
so I didn't want to turn this into an
arrow talk if you haven't poked it Arrow
if you have not poked at the arrow
project all I'm going to say is poke at
the arrow project you'll be left behind
if you don't
um so because arrow is the one that's
going to enable a lot of the it is
enabling and we'll continue to enable a
lot of this access to language agnostic
Cutting Edge data analysis and data
analysis and visualization tools
um there will be maybe a week's Delay
from the next coolest thing that someone
makes out there to being usable inside
quarto in some way shape or form this is
this is going to be the experimentation
and delivery platform of the it's
present but also in the future the thing
that I I think maybe like about it more
than anything else is like I get to tap
into really smart people that can make
things Beautiful by giving me all the
designs and styles and sets and I just
have to apply them so it's uniform
styling across any documentation website
any publicly facing website any tool
application website out there document
presentations everything that's out
there this actual shell of our
presentation that I'm using here is a
template that I put up I have a link to
it in here that anyone can use that you
can modify for your own organization and
build upon it for those same rules that
are out there that uniformity makes
people want to dive in because
everything looks similar and looks as
beautiful as the other things they're
used to and if you've you know done your
best to make that the text accessible
and the expectation is accessible and
the visualization's accessible you've
just brought people into your data
science ecosystem in a way that you
haven't been able to do before I already
just talked about reproducibility I
think this is like the ultimate
reproducibility tester for organizations
um I think uh adaptability is is not
thought of as much as it probably should
be right now but this is basically like
this is mobile this is web this is pad
this is VR like this is like it's not
just adaptable to that platform but it's
adaptable to interactive into static
because I'm about to render this into
PDFs to to give to the nycr folks as
well
um I I I know you're not just they are
folks anymore with the hackers gotcha
um but this is this is you know this is
amazing like you have choices you can do
really great things and have output in
ways that you really had never had
before even in the r markdown like the
system because the the tooling is a
little bit safer a little bit easier to
use and a little bit like more
guaranteed to the applets that you're
going to get when you do that
um and you'll get Fame and Fortune um
I'm not as good with reveal.js so I was
going to put a little thing in the
bottom it says statement Fortune not
guaranteed but um you know that's your
mileage may vary with that one on there
um so where are you going to start with
all these things as we come to a close
um well I already said it but you got to
go to quota.org digest every single
thing there it's not huge there's not a
vast amount of information and I would
suggest doing it as you need to learn a
particular thing so if you want to make
interesting presentations uh in a nice
accessible JavaScript framework that
also like will produce great PDF content
Etc maybe start with there if you want
to just see how you can switch over your
markdowns or your python notebooks maybe
take that track on there you can kind of
design your own courses you want to do
on the quarter website
um you need you absolutely I will not I
cannot pronounce the name like I'm going
to say Michael because I'm disconnecting
it's fine to Kyle
um the awesome core that's a that's a
link so you can go to it um it's it's a
GitHub repo but it's also just an
amazing collection of resources every
single new thing he catches things
before I do that's that's saying a lot
of people like catches on Friday
um that's amazing you need to go there I
don't know how he does that I hope
people just keep submitting all the cool
stuff that you make on there oh Thomas's
and lots of the other our studio work is
in in there of the presentation
tutorials it's just phenomenal resources
some so many creative people doing so
much creative amazing work to help other
folks dive into this ecosystem
um get up cozy like have coffee time
virtual or otherwise with with your
design Folks at work I'm sure most orgs
have some sort of designer whether it's
outsourced or insourced or however you
do it
um they will level up your communication
skills because they know how to make
things beautiful and you might too I've
seen so many amazing folks that just
knew R are now like CSS and scss and
JavaScript experts it's just amazing
seeing that progression for folks uh way
better than I am at those things um I
I'm relying heavily on my awesome team
at work to kind of give me these great
things
um I would argue creating a website
would be a great thing to start with but
build up some some muscle
um I have not I've done that internally
I've not done that externally yet I I
will probably do that at some point
um and then there's this thing called
freezing content so building websites
really scary because quarter render
like it requires reproducibility and if
you have multiple things coming into
there reproducing the whole thing you
know initially it's going to break for a
while like it's not you're not going to
get reproduced reproducibility out of
the gate so the way I've been trying to
do this uh in our setup that we're like
just getting off the ground at work
um is we're freezing all the content
that each individual person generates
with their own individual tooling
eventually that's I'm gonna go like
that's it we're going to court a render
and like like close my eyes and hope it
actually works
um freezing content lets you basically
like let the person on their machine
make everything work you just generate
content and just serve up the content
via web server um it's a really nice
happy meeting between dealing all that
plus that also has some performance
benefits especially if you're one of
those folks that uses GitHub actions
don't use good actions
um
and then you're going to want to learn
rocker um so that's like the docker
ecosystem for R but is it just for R I
think if it is the data science
um ecosystem because uh once you have
rocker and you get some of the
fundamentals working um within that for
just standing up various stuff relating
to Cordo
um you should read about extending
doctors so these are all links and like
this is one of the better I thought
better length is from the carpentries uh
for how to extend Docker because you're
going to want to add in all the things
that work for everybody else so you can
make a reproducible environment with
these things and then generate the stuff
via that reproducible environment so
you're building your skill sets here if
you already aren't I know a lot of our
folks have already been in Python folks
and it's ever been doing this already uh
but this is a kind of a great learning
path
um for for doing things like that's the
progression that I'd like to recommend
for folks actually go do
um and then I've got some resources for
folks as well too I'm going to tap
through them all um actually I'm uh so
the first one uh I and I have to update
this one so like by rbware
um I I like staying really current on
our studio I I'm sort of like really
obsessed with it and I also like as a
result of that need to stay really
current with quarter because they kind
of go hand in hand I haven't updated
this there's a new version of Cordo
um there's a preview release that you
need to do some cool features I have not
updated that into the installer yet but
if you want to keep your electron based
R studio for Max
um and quarter off the date at the same
time run that every day and you'll get
you'll get a pristine version of that
every day and it's smart enough to know
if you've got the latest version of
everything too so I won't do that the
quarter organization template is
literally this template that you can
customize with like actual decent I
think decent interruptions no one told
me they weren't uh to do that uh the
next three things are just examples of
how you kind of just maybe bring our
data in or use already do data some work
and then pass stuff over to observable a
couple different things on there to be
able to go do that if you want to
actually eat that fourth link if you're
in the US and you want to keep track of
how I won't be political I promise I
won't see if you want to keep track of
the elections in November you can do
that with that with that fourth one
um the one down from there I it's
something that I kind of do every year
almost every year for for our folks is I
do I regenerate the uh foliage map and R
with like using animation this is a
version of it that actually uses R for
the data grabbing and then uses
observable to kind of get the rest of it
um and that bottom one is if you don't
want to actually install a Chrome
extension because you should all be very
careful and never install Chrome
extensions if you can all avoid it
that's a rust based command line tool
that you pointed at any observable
notebook and we'll do the exact same
thing that the extension does if you
want to be able to siphon off all that
cool things and look at the cool
JavaScript code that people have written
to help you make cool stuff
um so does it ask me anything time so
whatever you've typed in or still want
to type in from on there uh the source
is there but you probably already have a
link to all those things and that's a QR
code
for that it's safe I I I I will tell you
if I'm going to compromise you I promise
I will tell you that uh that's a that's
a QR code generated with python at the
very end of the document so again if if
you haven't all died from the fact that
I've not used python multiple times in
this document
um I I guess you're still going to be
reading for this one
um but with that I'm going to stop my
share before I jump in first round of
applause for
Bob thank you so much uh we have a bunch
of questions uh I'm going to uh jump in
and and ask uh them I'm going to roll up
some of the ones that we had early on
how does Porto connect with uh you know
and I'll summarize like in a sense
non-quarter tools uh for communicating
through things like uh slack or officer
SharePoint or other debate or sort of
other ecosystems that are not data
ecosystems uh for organizations
actually that's a really good question
um so I let me let me I will weave my
way through through what you just said
so uh depending on what so I don't know
how you want to communicate in slack um
thanks I I am so thankful that some
other folks take the burden of slacker
off of me so if you're using slack bar
other people have it now they're doing
amazing work with it
um but that's just a connector to kind
of go do things and like like most
people communicate in slack via Bots or
you're going to post something manually
physically into there
um so a couple things about that
um one one thing I despise about slack I
I mean see I'm opinionated is the fact
that like if you drop an HTML and slack
rightfully so because you're running a
full electron horrible electron browser
or inside slack for most people or
running or browser
um by giving you an HTML like bad things
could happen when you just run on
trusted HTML because it's running a
bunch of other stuff inside there so it
doesn't render HTML you can't do
interactive HTML inside it's like I I
that's great I'm glad they did it that
way so all the interactive stuff that I
just I was explaining to you even that
like the very simple
um observable word cloud I did won't
work in slack so that functionality
you're just not going to get in slack
but there literally is nothing stopping
you from having something that uses
Cordo to render a document into like PDF
uh because actually there's a pretty
decent PDF viewer in like because they
use one of the open source JavaScript
PDF viewers and sites like to be able to
do that or or a word doc or something
like that to put it into there
um or you could use something that
actually generates like a workflow where
you generate a really awesome beautiful
document in Cordo uh generate a like a
docx and have like one of the amazing r
or python systems that drop stuff into
Google Sheets or whatever other Echo
System you do Cloud stuff in post those
links into there as well too so quarto
itself isn't going to get you that Cordo
is the communication mechanism and the
Beautiful recommend things it's going to
get you the ability to make the
beautiful stuff for there but I also
argue you could also have a website that
you build with Cordo and drop the links
into the slack with those because it
Cordo is also smart enough like these
folks are amazing like it does all the
open graph tags like one of my as you as
everyone that I've ever worked with will
be glad to let you know I have my
biggest pet peeve is a no unfurling open
graph tags in slack like I will
literally scream like in the house when
that happens
um but it does that you have open graph
tags in there so like it actually won't
make things look pretty into there so I
think that's how you tie stuff into
there and the same goes to SharePoint
right you can actually create word docs
that SharePoint will render and index
pretty well but you can also throw a PDF
in the SharePoint as well too I mean you
should really try to get your orgs in
order to use SharePoint it's a terrible
thing it's really insecure um it's just
horror I mean I I know you also have no
ability to do that because the organ's
been using it forever and they buy steak
dinners for all the team managers
um but except but again the content you
create can be used and pushed up to
there and there's connectors and every
language that you can use to push stuff
content out so I would say like work it
from there like get really good at
making the design and everything
beautiful and the document's Beautiful
where you can make interactive stuff
where you can't make static and use that
as a publishing mechanism for those
things
all right
um let's uh get a question from the
slack here question from Miles McBain uh
so uh so what do you think about uh Lua
being the standard language for writing
quarto extensions
um so as someone who's been in cyber and
other things for a long time like Lua is
a big friend of folks in cyber psych I I
love Lua um you that I used to have
something on crayon called uh Splash R
which was a alternative to our selenium
for uh doing JavaScript enable web
scraping in a package I relied on died
and because of plus Prince cran like
everything that went with it died
um so it's not there anymore like the
way you scripted that was with Lua and
not JavaScript and at the end like back
in the day I was a way better Lewis
scripture than I am a JavaScript or was
a JavaScript or
um so I think that Lua is is really nice
it's also probably a little safer in
certain aspects than other languages
they actually could have used for that
and it's also the scripting language and
one reason why I love it by miles it's
it's the scripting language for most
gaming platforms and what I want to get
is all and I'm because like I can I can
say this because I am not one I want to
get all the younger people
um who are still coming into this and
are enamored with the gaming scene but
then work in that brutal industry for a
while and want to escape it I know it's
because my my daughter does gaming
program
um but they they won't know look because
it powers like so many games out there
like so they they come with first hand
like Lua knowledge that will put all of
us in this oh I think pretty much in
this in this channel to shame
um so you get to bring them on board and
help with those things too so it's it
really is like a great level Setter I
mean and come on like this like like one
of my newsletters talked about how
amazing Louisville was too so you should
be usually gonna read that if you
haven't um so I think it's great and I
think it's flexible I think it's
extendable I think it's a little memory
footprint but I'm more and I'm more
happy like I just said because it's
bringing it has the ability to bring way
more people into our ecosystem than it
did before
I will say I have talked to JJ a little
bit about this and they're not
completely against the idea of opening
up uh the ability to sort of use you
know use one of the general scripting
languages and but one of the uh to to
build extensions but uh one of the main
reasons they they want it is for that
reproducibility uh thing because uh with
Lua it's embeddable and it can travel
and with the whole system that that but
if you if you do this then the if the
extensions are in one of the many
languages that quarter supports uh then
that needs to be the language that
people are are running in order for to
run run the quarto extensions yeah I
mean I I would argue I would argue that
if I were going to if I were if I were
like I I don't contribute to quarter
like at all for less than once a reason
um mostly his time
um the
I would argue if there's an extension at
all to how you do how what they're gonna
all support for to you know add that
capability that Lua provides for folks
that for folks that don't know this just
really quick so Lua lets you create
pandok filters but other things as well
too inside this quarter system pandok is
still like I love Panda because like it
all the Haskell people love it too
because like it's the biggest Pony of
the century people pandok is written in
Haskell everyone runs more Haskell code
than you even knew you're running before
like Haskell like owns everything I just
love how they did that to everybody
um but that's how you like write those
filters in there what I'd rather see is
a Wazi which is a um webassembly systems
interface interface to pandok so that I
could write rust and have it go to wasm
and I could write R and go to waslam
because you can write R and go to wasm
now guys it's great George is amazing um
python like all this like so like I
think that is the level Setter and I
would really I'd rather see anything
private anything else that's gonna be
doing extensiony things and because you
can come out Lua to wazam as well too so
anyway I I will get off my walls and
time Wars um so like I love I love Lua
I'd even like I'd even love it better if
they have if they had a wazy interface
to it
okay uh question for someone else and
he's gone in some other areas
um so uh someone was asking what's a
good introduction to CSS or bootstrap
for those of us who are trying to learn
how to uh tweak themes and styling in
quarto
um why you're not gonna want to hear
this
um do you Source
um I I'm really sad I'm like I'm sorry
so I I guess that's a little bit
cheating because like that's kind of
what I I've been viewing source for
probably 14 15 years longer than
everybody else here has so like that
doesn't count because like I've had 14
15 years to do source and you only have
like a year a day uh I don't have off
the top my head a resource but I do have
incredible resources at my at my day job
who are more brilliant and do things
with this so well so I will get them to
give me a list of that but I will also
then cheat and say like I will put it in
my newsletter next week
um so you can have to go to there to get
the information for their just to cheat
and get some more sign up to the
newsletter yeah we can also cheat and
save that any you know we have a lot of
people here who probably know a little
bit of that yeah so yeah y'all doesn't
answer please drop it in in the chat
yeah seriously guys like that's folks
that's like I'm I'm active deliberately
trying to not say guys I usually go say
folks
um the the the you like go to that list
um the awesome quarter list read a bunch
of the blogs because some some folks on
there didn't know a thing about scss
before and they got into quarter and
they started reading everything and like
this they make some of the most
beautiful things and they became experts
in this stuff like they just they
clicked with them so read some of those
resources there too because I've just
been amazed at what people have been
creating with this and how quickly they
picked some of that stuff up so they may
they're also probably good resources to
go to see maybe what their mental model
was to kind of because really it's
adapting that mental model around how
scss works and then how CSS Works
thankfully if you're just getting into
it now CSS and scss makes a lot more
sense now than it did five eight years
ago um it's a way more like the mental
model is almost solidified to the point
where I think almost anyone can pick it
up
okay uh here's a question about uh
observable and Porto uh so what did you
mean that uh and I'm trying to remember
specifically where this was uh about uh
that about uh setting up the data in the
right way to load into observable oh
yeah yeah that's great so there's um so
I will focus
um R because why wouldn't you
um the so I I'm really I think I'm
pretty good at data manipulation in our
data getting in our massaging on there
uh we love data frames in our like I
think if I were to ask everyone in this
like we all love data frames like we
live and buy die by The tabular Format
um and what's and like our mental models
of how things work with data frames in R
and even in pandas or whatever
um they're they're way different than
what that format looks like when you
throw it to JavaScript so like when you
serialize a data frame let's say with
with i i for the folks that are Json um
Json Lite you see realize that into
there one of two different ways one is
an array of objects and one is just like
a stream of objects that kind of get put
out to there
almost nothing in JavaScript likes that
like like almost nothing in JavaScript
likes the format that I just set on to
there
um they they actually have a way of
naming objects and ways of using object
keys and values to make things more
accessible and more performant inside
the the JavaScript ecosystem uh so what
what they did and like I think this like
I think I remember reading or someone
was saying it it wasn't an afterthought
but they're like yeah let's just commit
let's make a couple of extra functions
that people could use to call from
JavaScript to transform these things so
this existed in HTML widgets before but
it's not on steroids inside of this
ecosystem so what you can do is when you
have like say an R chunk do some stuff
with data you have that data in R you
say push there's a command you there's
like basically a function you call that
will say make this available to
observable and observable you say give
me this thing and it make it makes it
available and observable and they say
this other thing transform it into
something that JavaScript you'll
understand because javascript's kind of
deaf sometimes
um so it's literally like two things to
run and it immediately transfers that
data over makes it available inside the
inside the output for the of the
notebook and transformed it into
something that most of the things that
you can plug into with D3 will just
operate on immediately obviously you
need to know the names of things are
whatever
um so it's really straightforward to go
through those things and one of like two
of the notebooks in that links that I
provide are on there uh they show you
how to actually go do that because like
that was the bees and ease to me like I
just I I literally I wouldn't holler a
lot I mean I'm home alone so no one
really hears me
um so like I I was so excited when I saw
that and that worked and I just I use it
all the time now um so if you have any
problems or need more questions I mean I
am on Twitter over constantly so like
you should hit me up there and I'll be
glad to help
okay here's a a great very Bob question
why did you say not to use GitHub
actions
um I I hate Microsoft with the passion
and a fire that I can't contain
sometimes um that's that's pretty much
and like it's just a way of making
Microsoft more money in the long run
because they're going to tell you at
some point you can't win this because
you run out of credits and then you're
going to buy a per it's I I don't like
the lock so it's like I will take this
offline I have to say it's one of my
opinions I don't like
uh uniform locked in ecosystems I don't
like the fact that GitHub has pretty
much become the de facto social coding
service out there yes I know other ones
exist but but 90 million daily users I
think is what they said they get now
which is just terrifying
um so yeah I just don't like it I I am I
I have reverted to only doing stuff on
GitHub because I'm busy I just there's
one life is really busy I've got a
wonderful grandchild now
um so like I've I've given in but if you
can at all not give in to that and try
to keep doing stuff in different ways
please please do guy I I just don't like
Microsoft and GitHub actions are not
always safe if you look there has been a
number of of ish there have been a
number of security issues with them
people have found holes into them and
now they're primarily used to do coin
mining which is great because we need
more cryptocurrency mining out there um
so I just don't like them period it's
it's me use them uh there's lots of
great documentation the rstudio fam does
an amazing job of showing you how to use
them have a lot of great ones out there
if it will save you time and save you
trouble and not make you bring your hair
out which I don't think it does because
every I hear people complaining about
them all the time when it comes to some
of these things especially
um you know maybe don't like I I'm just
not a big fan of it
okay I knew I knew that would set you
off
um
uh there's a another question a question
related to uh uh a little bit of
security which is uh I wonder if you
could give a little more detail about
like how you have set up using Porto
within your organization one of the
questions is how you set it up in terms
of uh you know what's your approach in
terms of uh access and security and auth
and the link to that but also like
what's the the to the extent that you
have one this the system that like
you've got some people on to use quarto
yeah so um like so I like I am I am
still Dragon Kicking and Screaming
python people uh actually that's
entirely not true
um the one person that I have to
convince has been on paternity so I
can't really convince someone that's
been on paternity to go do something
except handle the beautiful little baby
uh so that's the that's the one thing
there um and we so we are
I'm gonna I'm gonna limit this and if
Matt's on I'm sorry Matt
um we are kubernetes shop for Better or
For Worse so we have kubernetified I
have no idea what the word is for that
um but we we have cooged Kate Kate's
cated whatever
um that the the setup on there and so
right now we're in that baby step stage
which is one reason why I showed you the
baby step thing so it's a this works on
Bob's computer so Bob's going to do the
render and we're going to just have
content that displays via an nginx web
server that goes onto there because
that's how it works I know that when the
other folks get a chance to get into it
it's going to work fine on there as well
too
um it's also the least resource
intensive because like I don't have to
spend a lot of money because it's a
budget thing I have to pay for the stuff
we use at work
um so I got to spend a lot of money on
the kubernetes environment or beefing
that up to kind of make sure it can do
all that sorts of things when I've got
literally like a Mac Studio that's it's
unused half the day sometimes
um so like I'd rather use the local
compute resources and do that out to
there the eventual goal though is to do
exactly what you indicated what I was
saying is
um have folks there make sure everybody
can reproduce things on their own
environment but actually have that
dockerized environment which will do
that whole make thing and we will freeze
content because it makes sense from a
time and savings and everything
standpoint but every so often we should
be running things to make sure we can
reproduce everything we do from the from
the coms standpoint just like we do from
the API and ml Ops input on the other
side of the house as well too
um secondarily
um like so I've been on a tear to have
like local pie pie and there's some
really new cool stuff that I'll be
hopefully trying out tomorrow and also
putting in the newsletter about so I
will do something in the newsletter for
r i don't just ignore it I try if if I
start doing R in the newsletter Norm I
know I'm I said Norm on Twitter that's
why I said if I if I start doing R in
the newsletter it's just going to take
it over so I have to like it I have to
be careful how often I put R in the
newsletter
um but there's a great new thing that
lets you do secure our repos with like
all sorts of great stuff around it and
if it works great I'll be blattering
about to everybody I want both of those
things set up so that we have both
secure sourcing of the packages that we
actually use for both our python
whatever
um and then they'll be able to kind of
and so for as an off that you said so we
do every single thing so nothing we have
is secret from the rest of the company
that we do in like at all like there's
nothing secret except Personnel things
um so everything but we're we're like a
radical transparency organization the
also all that stuff exists on a you have
to exist over the VPN you have to be VPN
in fully with that to be able to see any
of the content that we actually render
on those things so there's nothing
public about anything that we actually
go do for this stuff that doesn't need
to be any auth I see that happening down
the road
um and there was a great discussion on
Twitter this week about maybe using
shinyproxy to handle some of the off
stuff so I will definitely be blathering
more about that once we actually set
those kind of things up I watched that
thread that I was in I think Miles was
in it too earlier this week yeah
uh uh little question outside quarto uh
one question is uh what's your system
for uh collecting and organizing and
Publishing all of the links and tools
that you put in your newsletter almost
every day and and as well as your your
blog every week
um so uh I so I use I I feebly did
something that I will not talk about
that I don't use feeding anymore and I
don't encourage people to use Feedly
um I I do use inner reader now and I
love in a reader um if you there's a
free tier there's a page here I use the
page here because I'd use a lot more the
features than people that don't use that
so I use inner reader religiously with a
lot of connections I probably go through
30 000 articles a day and inner reader
um so like I I and I I do a lot of
sifting I do a lot of reading and I do a
lot of whatever like you know like I
don't read every single one of 30 000
things
I use that in conjunction with another
thing called raindrop.io
um yeah I love raindrop.io is just a
beautiful service it is a beautiful
utility is just phenomenal I've even
wired up all my so you can wire up
everything to it I just wired up Twitter
faves to it so I actually get to have
those resources available there too uh
all that together in combination with uh
Visual Studio code and a bunch of
extensions and then also room research I
use personally I use Rome I find that to
be more usable than everything else and
I don't just I don't I just don't want
to deal with the city like I love
obsidian but Rome I don't have to do
anything it just works so um okay so all
those things together let me have an
understanding it's like sometimes some
days are better than others sometimes
they have a really good theme and a good
thing sometimes I'm in a random mood so
I'll pick random things
um that kind of goes out there but I'm
pretty much constantly watching
everything and one reason for that it's
not just because it's whatever like in
cyber like I have to be watching for any
of the ladies things that pop up uh
there's another one of there's another
person at work that does it even better
than I do
um and like he's even maybe bit more
insane than I am um but like kind of the
same thing just constantly monitoring
everything it's a it's a residual effect
from cyber stuff but it also the impact
that I get to keep up with a lot of the
tech stuff
let me ask uh my question about which is
a big question by Porto which is sort of
quarto in another organizational
environment uh okay so you made a great
case for why Porto brings all of these
other people into the ecosystem who come
into because they have uh experience
with python or Lua or or rust and they
come from other other places in Tech uh
but a lot of our users come into our
where our being is the only coding they
do right you're gonna say Excel I say
you're gonna say Excel no they're not
even that they're not even Excel but
they might be they might be Excel use R
is the only coding do because most of
what they do is encoding at all and they
like worked really hard so that they can
make the the graph for the one thing
they do which is you know otherwise you
know going out and Counting snakes in a
forest and
and making and making the graph and
they've learned that ggplot and they've
learned that our markdown and that you
know they've gotten that far right and
that's an important thing and then you
say well let's go install and let's
change to the next thing instead right
so from the perspective of someone who's
in a sense just the you know just the
just the r user and not in a tech
organization necessarily like what is
Porto what is the new things that
quarter brings people that they might
not you know have have thought and that
makes it worth the cost of installing
the new thing where you know there's
where it's a much higher uh barrier to
installing the new thing instead of the
new thing than people who always try a
new tool yeah that's
um
I'm I saw I'm going to background
process that well well I say a couple
things are around that um so like I I
sometimes take it for so
um there's things on my wrist one of the
things on my wrist is this thing called
and like I'm not like it's one of the
tracker devices I won't mention the
names on here but you can probably see
what it is if anyone knows what it is
um I've had this for lots of reasons
because one like I for a long time like
I just didn't actually really sleep uh
so that's one thing that initially
enabled me to keep up with a lot of
things that are out there but I actually
use this to sleep just enough that I
need to to be able to stay and kind of
basically so I can't tell everyone to
kind of well yeah just like drink a lot
of caffeine but then also get the right
amount of sleep so your body's healthy
but then also just kind of nerd out and
do this kind of stuff because everyone
wants to do something else like watch
sports ball or whatever
um and um so what I guess I would say
that person if if what you're doing
right now if you're a solo or you're
like one person in a tiny org and you've
got something that works like and you've
got people that are giving you feedback
that this communication is great it's
helpful I understand it it's useful to
me I and we we use it and we make
decisions with it and you haven't like I
can't tell you not I can't tell you to
switch I one thing I will tell you is
and I know there's like three of you
that are going to go but I tried it
didn't work and yeah I'm sorry it
doesn't work for everything if it's not
a markdown thing that does a GT plot
like that just works in Cordo like it
it's just it really does almost work
everybody it almost does work it will it
will work perfectly soon but almost
every single thing is it works perfectly
in it than it does in our Mark so if
that is it
um I would say first quarto is a single
binary install
sync like the package install in every
system so you don't have to know how to
do anything else that's out there if
it's an R thing you've already got R
installed so you can deal with that on
there if you've got if you're if you're
already doing a python you're already
doing it in Python so you've got that on
there as well too so it's one more
binary and it's a command line tool is
we're not talking a giant ID like our
studio or like like vs code it's one
more binary and if that one binary
switch out lets someone else maybe help
you make things prettier because maybe
you got feedback that it isn't as
helpful or maybe it isn't communicating
it is as well as it could or it's not as
if not as pristine as it could be
because like there's some just as an
example like there's recent studies that
just got posted this past week that I
already blathered about that shows
annotation directly on charts gets
better response from people that
actually interpret those charts and read
those charts as just a general person
maybe that person isn't doing that and
they're going to go do that or if you're
going to touch it why don't you touch it
and touch quarter at the same time just
because I don't think everything is
static I don't think things remain the
same I think things that do you probably
aren't that useful in the long run
um but so those two things like maybe I
can't convince you if it's a if it's
already perfect and everyone works with
it and you're you need to be productive
and do what you do but I think that I
can build a use case for almost anybody
to give it a try
not sure so here's an interesting sort
of question from the other side which is
from sort of Michael Steve which is that
uh What uh is the the argument you would
make to uh so that the non-coder but not
on the production side but on the
consumption side right that uh says you
know like you should like support the
teams or the infrastructure other things
so that they can use quarto right
um you know be it like give them the
server they need or give them the access
on their machines to run it on they need
right like what is it what are the the
consumers of the outputs gonna get
um for an organization using quartet
so the consumer side
um I I would I would argue you give them
the first decent internet there's a lot
of ice I have I have feels about
interactive visualizations we can have a
conversation on Twitter at any time
about that
um I'm a static first person I will
always be a static first person
um but I believe that there are there is
good use cases for um interactive
visualization I think if you can show
someone a really and I I I'm blanking
off the top of my head there's a really
great observable HQ presentation online
this week or next week and I'll try to
get it and blah blah they're back on
Twitter blast it back on Twitter again
um from folks talking about like how to
actually do this and it's from an actual
real practical thing where it's like a
heat map associated with like Health
Data
um you do one of those and people have
the ability to go explore data in the
way they did before
um and it looks really good and it fits
with The Branding that your organization
has and you you use and like and you did
that like you or your team did that you
suddenly got everyone to buy like
everyone's like oh can I have more of
this please like so I I mean I I'm not
trying to encourage drug use but like
it's like it's like it's like a crack
dealer right you're going to give them a
little bit of a great thing and they're
going to go whoa can I have some more of
that and then you just kind of put down
that Pipeline Supply uh to kind of go
out there so just try it
um because some of it's like like there
are some things we'll be producing over
the next couple of weeks and produces
making it visible but I've done all the
experimentation with like inside
observable like inside a quarto between
art and observable and it's just going
to be out into the real world
and it's and it isn't just vanilla basic
stuff either it's kind of I think it's
kind of neat stuff so like I you know
just try that you try the trickle out
get some practice at it and definitely
focus on interactive first because
that's where some of the really big
benefits of this are but then that you
like your ability to communicate stuff
from your team in a really accessible
way in a really beautiful way will also
probably get you better funding within
your organization better support within
your organization folks knocking out
your door to do more of that other work
that like I said that my team does like
the bi work the sales work and all the
other stuff too
yeah yeah Maya yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Maya oh Maya's awesome yeah thank
you yeah yeah so the in in in the chat
with uh yeah I was talking about all the
stuff that is uh um that is coming up
this presentation from my again so yeah
Maya's awesome
okay well we're we're at 30 which I
think is sort of our our informal end
time so uh everybody let's thank Bob
again for uh a great and passionate and
super informative presentation uh which
I certainly learned uh a lot from uh it
was a good opportunity uh thank you all
for joining us uh tonight uh once again
look out we got uh the new 4J conference
coming up we got RN government coming up
and then next month again for everybody
around the world can join us in hybrid
but for those in New York uh can join us
uh for tof Allen's talk uh done Soho and
you should if you're a member or if
you're not a member who want to uh
become a member uh look out for that
announcement uh at the end of this week
or early next week so thank you all very
much once again thanks Bob uh and have a
good night everybody